you mentioned that uh doge is the the
people's coin
yeah um and you said that you were
literally going spacex may
consider literally putting
a dosh coin on
the moon
is this something you're still
considering uh mars perhaps
uh do you think there's some chance
we've talked about political systems on
mars that uh dogecoin is the
official currency of mars that's
happening in the future
well i i think mars itself will
need to have a different currency
because you can't synchronize due to
speed of light
or not easily um so must be completely
stand alone from earth
well yeah because the
but
mars is at closest approach it's four
light minutes away roughly and then add
for this approach uh it's roughly 20
light minutes away
maybe a little more um
so you can't really have uh something
synchronizing you know if you could if
if you've got a 20 minute speed of light
issue if it's got a one minute
blockchain
it's not going to synchronize properly
so mars
would i don't know if moss would have a
cryptocurrency as a thing but probably
seems likely
um but it would be some kind of
localized thing on mars um
and you let the people decide
yeah absolutely
the future of mars should be after the
martians
you